so good evening I'm Dr goodie Singh and
I'm delighted to welcome you to this
intelligent squared event at the Francis
quick Institute in London now the Crick
as it's known is a leading Center for
biomedical research that is at the
Forefront of advances in genome editing
our theme for this evening now tonight
we'll be discussing whether Gene editing
is the next great health Revolution and
what this could mean for the future of
humanity now I need to let you know that
there has been a slight change in our
panel you may have noticed and instead
of Professor Robin level badge who is
sadly unwell this evening we have in his
place the brilliant molecular biologist
Dr Ganesh Taylor who I will introduce
along with the rest of our amazing
panelists shortly
now before we get into this evening's
conversation why are we here today the
last decade has seen rapid advances in
the development of Gene editing
techniques ever since a biological tool
called crispr was developed to edit and
replace sections of DNA in living
organisms this revolutionary technique
can be used to help treat diseases such
as cystic fibrosis sickle cell anemia
and some cancers and its potential
extends much further than this
we're at a stage where genome editing
will radically transform the way we
treat and see human health
but when scientific advances take place
in a vacuum unintended consequences can
occur so it's vital that the public has
a say in the way that this technology is
applied
so this event coincides with a free
exhibition here at the creek called cut
and paste which runs until December 2023
created in partnership with the creative
Studio the liminal space cut and paste
is a fascinating Hands-On exhibition
and it investigates the ethics of Gene
editing and what this means for human
diversity and our relationship with our
bodies
we'll be exploring some of the themes
here tonight
so before I kick off the conversation
let me introduce our fantastic panel so
here in the room we have Dr Ganesh
Taylor a postdoctoral research scientist
at the Francis Crick Institute
she specializes in using cutting-edge
technology I think that's a bit of a pun
there do you understand how reproductive
systems are built she's spoken alongside
popular scientists and experts such as
Richard Dawkins you've all know Noah
Harari and Lord Robert Winston
we also have lovely Shani danda an
award-winning disability activist and
inclusion inclusion specialist and Tom
Whipple science editor at the Times
and also joining us from the live stream
we have Jimmy olajair who is based in
the US and one of was one of the first
people in the world to receive a form of
gene therapy to treat sickle cell
disease
I'd actually like to start with you and
find out where exactly we are with the
advances in genetic experimentation I
mean it feels like to me we're at a
unique moment in time in terms of what
we're able to do in terms of
manipulating genes and yet I'm sure many
people listening to this will be
thinking well we've done genetic
modification before
what makes this different what is it
about crispr technology that has pushed
this on so much further
yes
um yes that's an excellent question we
thought by changing the name to genome
editing people might have not noticed
that it was in fact just genetic
modification but clearly I haven't
fooled you
um yes so the important thing to say is
um
well crispr is just a new form of
Technology basically it's just another
platform
um for doing something that we were
doing before and the best analogy
actually I have for this is it's a bit
like the first smartphone
to mobile phones and communication in
general telephones existed before mobile
phones existed before but we all kind of
remember probably the first Apple iPhone
that came out and thinking okay this is
a total Game Changer and it is so crispr
crisper cast 9 as it's called is a game
changer because
um of its Precision importantly okay
it's significantly more precise
um and programmable than previous
generations of Technology available for
altering and modifying DNA and that
Precision means that we can achieve far
greater results it's also faster to
utilize and leverage in the lab so
that's also important and it's pretty
cheap too so all those things definitely
help but the reason why this has been so
revolutionary is because of this
programmable Precision that it brings
um meaning that now basically
anything that we know of that is encoded
in DNA whether it's in plants animals or
human beings is up for modification
right so that's exactly it it's a
Precision isn't it because what we're
looking at here is being able to change
the genetic codes we're talking about
there the genetic alphabet in any
species not just humans and there's
something specific about this
specificity isn't there in terms of the
kinds of diseases that this can impact
there's certain kinds of conditions that
this is really really good for well I
mean well yes in particular
um if you're thinking about human beings
and if you're thinking about the
diseases that human beings get any
disease that we know is attributable to
a single disease to a single um Gene
excuse me in particular is is a prime
candidate for this for this technology
because if you know with certainty this
Gene AE whatever it is causes this
disease we can now deal with it of
course not all diseases are attributable
to a single disease and single Gene
excuse me and so you know there is some
limitation therefore for what we could
potentially do yeah actually yeah yeah
okay so this Precision is what's making
it all so exciting but there are some
challenges and there are some current
limitations with the technology in terms
of using it more widely aren't there and
is it is it simply that that it's too
precise to be able to be used for
anything that's more complicated or or
are there other issues with it
no so I think I would say just so you
know just to
remind you all I'm sure you're all aware
so crispr cas9 is a is a or crispr for
short is a two-part molecular system
importantly and there's the crisp a bit
that's the bit that's programmable that
you can encode to say this is the piece
of DNA I'm looking for that I want you
to go find and then there's the cas9 bit
and the cas9 bit is the sort of doing
end of of the the setup
and what's really fascinating about this
technology is a bit like um iPhones have
changed over time we've also already
started modifying this platform so you
can change the cas9 to have different
functions and different
um effects basically and so there's
actually quite a lot that you can do
with this technology in fact you know
the the Opera the range of things that
we can do is really quite wide but
um in terms of limitations
um well if you think about it
um crispr can be used to change DNA but
DNA exists in one copy per cell and each
one of us
approximately is several trillion cells
moving around through space which means
several trillion copies of genomes which
means if you want to change something
you you've got a real delivery problem
basically so the main limitation at the
moment or the big conundrum comes here
which is
all of us start off life as one cell and
then we become several trillion cells so
we have this technology it can be used
to edit things in DNA DNA is really
important for health outcomes
at what point do you edit that DNA do
you do it when you are one genome big in
a single cell or do you do it when you
are several trillion cells big and
you've got a real delivery problem right
so therein lies the problem and therein
lies the big ethical conundrums and some
of the big questions that have Arisen
around the idea of things like designer
babies and what so forth but we will we
will come to that I think sorry just to
to be really explicit about this the
reason why doing an edit on a
single-celled embryo is
um ethically questionable or causes some
questions to be raised is just to be
really precise for everyone in the
audience the implication is if you edit
embryos that are really really small you
will edit the cells that will go on to
make the egg and sperm cells in the Next
Generation and so you edit them as well
whereas if you edit a body that already
exists it's called you know somatic you
just change your body you don't
necessarily change the egg and sperm
cells so that's really important yeah
it's heritable yeah yeah and I'm really
glad that you made that distinction
because what we're talking about there
is this idea that we could even
potentially be editing the evolution of
the human species which obviously has
massive implications
but I'd like to talk to jimin and bring
you into the conversation because in a
way you embody what we're talking about
all of the science that we've just been
talking about which is absolutely
fascinating
you've actually had first-hand
experience of What gene therapy can be
like now you lived with a condition
called sickle cell anemia since you were
born I wonder whether you could just
tell the audience here what is it like
to have sickle cell what was your
experience of it just so that we can
understand why it was so important for
you to have the therapy in the first
place my experience with sickle cell was
tough
it sometimes it felt like you know
climbing Mount Everest stacked on top of
Kilimanjaro there was no end in sight uh
constantly living out of hospitals of
course we all know the Cornerstone of
the disease is constant pain that just
constantly lingers and then all your
organs are also at play in Jeopardy I've
had a heart attack gallbladder taking
out a vascular necrosis it's just
um
insurmountable odds
that actually makes it quite difficult
to live you know so at some point in my
life I found myself really questioning
the quality of my life whether it's
actually even worth living with
everything that's going on with sickle
cell and you know with luck I found
crispr I thought it was going to be a
solution for the future 20 30 years in
the future and luckily I found this
article that came into my inbox and I a
qualified you know for something that I
thought was 20 years in the future it
happened two years after you know I'd
had this discussion with my parents to
try and figure out a way to improve my
quality of life
and life post-transplant is surreal
every day I wake up I'm still in awe I'm
still shocked as to what I'm able to do
compared to what my life was like before
uh pre-transplant you know the
about boundless amounts of energy that I
had before I couldn't even climb a
flight of stairs without taking a break
to catch my breath now I need people I
need people to tell me to slow down
because I I just you know I'm constantly
on the go because of how
um how crispr's really changed my life
one of the things I feel like it's
really given me is control you know for
as a young man you know as a teenager or
or a kid growing up you feel like your
parents kind of control your life
because they're adults and they kind of
direct you and then and then when you
get older you know you get to this
period where you think you're going to
take control of your life but in my case
I didn't have control of my life as well
Sickle Cell directed every aspect in
which my life went and then you know as
a 35 year old man I finally have control
of my life and it it is unreal
oh Jimmy it's really moving to hear you
talk about the transformative effect
that the gene therapy has had for you
and I'm so glad that you're able to
share the story with us just to clarify
for for the audience who are listening
um so sickle cell anemia is is a disease
that is basically caused by genetic uh
alteration in the hemoglobin structure
so that's what forms our blood cells and
when these blood cells are not forming
in the normal way they become sickle
shaped and they can have all sorts of
different symptoms and actually I wonder
whether Jimmy you could just tell us
some of the other symptoms as well as
pain that you had and how it would
present for you for you because again I
think it's just really important for
people to understand the impact that
conditions like this can have on
Ordinary People yeah absolutely I would
have these you know really violent pain
episodes that we'll call Sickle Cell
crisis that you know it's very difficult
to describe it just feels like your
whole body just is in a wave of pain
that can last for months you know where
you need intravenous medication in order
to control that pain so that you know
when I lived up north in in the
tri-state area that particularly in the
winter months that would happen almost
twice a week to two times sometimes you
know I'll be living out of the hospital
just to keep this pain under control
so that's one of the most important
pieces of sickle cell it's just that
constant pain and and when it escalates
and becomes chronic that you desperately
need to seek Hospital help that's when
it really gets bad but then like I said
you also have all because the blood
cells are all your organs basically need
good blood flow back and forth and with
sickle cell you don't have that good
blood flow so I had a heart attack once
because I wasn't having good blood flow
to my heart
um my gallbladder had to be taken out at
quite a young age as well because of the
same similar reasoning of just not
having enough blood flow to it and then
multiple pulmonary embolisms you know
acute chest syndrome pneumonia
it's a the disease is really the way it
manifests in your life and way it creeps
into it it's actually sometimes hard to
describe as obviously having a problem
because it goes into every facet you
know where you grow up where you where
you plan to go to school relationships
all of that it's um really really
difficult
yeah gosh and you're illustrating there
again just how important it is to think
about disease affecting every aspect of
a person's life and especially as a
child I mean this started when you were
from the day you were born right
um and what's really interesting to me
and a bit of your story that I think is
really interesting for the audience to
hear is that when you were a child you
were not in the states right you were in
Nigeria and that's part of why the
symptoms were so catastrophic in terms
of the treatment that you're able to
access and the healthcare there maybe
you could just talk a little bit about
that and then also then how you then
were able to get onto the crispr trial
okay
um so I was actually born here in the
states at the time 1985 in Nigeria they
didn't have the amniocentesis test that
would confirm if you have any genetic
condition my parents were fortunate
enough to fly my mom over while she was
pregnant to Washington DC she had that
amniocentesia test which in fact
confirmed that you know I would have
sickle cell and you know they still
decided to you know bring me to life
because back then I pray my mom told me
that you know the natural course of
action it particularly if you're from
Nigeria because people or children with
sickle cell in Nigeria didn't live past
the age of five so you know some doctors
they were off the belief that there's no
point in bringing a child to life that's
not going to see five years old but
because I was born here in the US I got
really fortunate you know they gave
birth to me here I became an American
citizen and
um you know we went back home like you
said uh to Nigeria for a little bit and
there was there's this one particular
story I think I told you when we uh you
know touched based earlier was um I used
to do this thing as a young boy at the
end of class I would go in in front of
the chalkboard in front of the
chalkboard and still chalk and I'll find
myself really taking all these create
substances and taking it home with me
and find myself in the corner eating
chalk eating foam and really thinking I
was going crazy
and then I moved over to the states and
that thing that was happening I had
these behaviors that I was manifesting
that yet turned out to be a condition
called Pika where you are lacking
nutrients so I was lacking a lot of
nutrients because I had sickle cell but
you know it just goes to show like you
said the at the time at least the
disparities in the two Health Care
system in one country I thought I was
nuts and in the other country it was
actually turned out to be a condition
that they were treating and you know
they gave me all these folic acid and
all these things so you know my body
wasn't in need of those nutrients
yeah and you know just to draw out again
that distinction between the different
Health Systems because I think this is
really important for us to think about
the global inequalities that exist right
in terms of what's available
um you're lucky enough now to be able to
talk to us about all of your experiences
you've had literally a 180 degree
reversal of your fortunes
um and I don't think it's exaggerating
for me to say that it has been
life-changing for you
um yeah but but of course you know that
has come by being uh in the United
States where you've had access to this
Cutting Edge technology and I wonder how
you think about
the Jimmy that might have stayed in
Nigeria or all the kids who are still in
Nigeria and don't have access to this
how does that make you feel
that's a fantastic question because I'm
a big believer in a stoic principle
called Amor Fati which is you know
loving one's fate and you know the irony
of me saying this is not lost on me
because I'm obviously through on the
other side but
that's that statement simply you know
simply it translated from Latin simply
means you know being happy with the
cards you're dealt you know no matter
how tragic your situation is you know if
while I was in the throes of the disease
if someone would have said that to me
I'd have been pissed if I'm honest
um
but you know I the the truth is I I only
time will tell I mean I definitely feel
uh and carry a lot of guilt too as well
for people that are not going to get to
access
um what I have access to at least not in
the next five to six years uh this
definitely
you know me going through the process
itself through a year
um I I don't even I can't even picture
how it's going to be you know
transported and made commercially ready
for places like Africa and India where
these therapies that desperately need it
you know I know they're working on
things called in Vivo now where we don't
have to do the conditioning that I had
to go through so I'm guessing that's
what it's going to be when these
therapies can be taken as a pill but I
can see that still being you know the
pill rather just a simple infusion but I
still see that being you know decades
and decades away from happening
hopefully not
thank you Jimmy and look this raises
this really important question about
what happens to Medical advances and you
know it's Gene editing today we had the
vaccine development during the pandemic
and it could even just be in terms of
like access to health skilled health
workers how are we Distributing this
stuff globally and it is a question that
you know I think we should park it for
now but I would like to come back to
that later but I want to bring you into
the conversation Shawnee because this
idea of fairness and this idea of
inequality is something that's very
close to my heart and I know something
that you care about deeply too and I
want to talk about this question of
inequalities in accessing cutting-edge
advances
um in science because it's obviously we
have inequalities in this country
um as well but maybe you could speak a
little bit about some of the experiences
you've had in terms of barriers to
accessing Quality Healthcare and what
have you seen both as a user but also in
your life as an activist so I was born
with a rare genetic Condition it's
called this fancy word osteogenesis
imperfecta it's more commonly known as
brittle bone disease it affects around
one in 20 000 people in the UK and it's
the conditions characterized by bones
that break without any trauma so
um it's like coughing and breaking a rib
it's like your bones are made out of
glass essentially
um and by the age of 14 I had broken my
legs six times
and I heard I heard the gasp that I
normally get but actually I'm very lucky
because people with my condition break
between three to four hundred times in
their life so I have nothing to complain
about you know what six breaks in
comparison
um
but although it's a genetic condition it
doesn't run in my family so I'm a
spontaneous mutation which is fun to be
and
um
so when I was born the doctors knew
something wasn't quite right didn't know
what it was then it took me two years to
get a diagnosis
um someone brought me originally uh came
down to great woman Street
um and you know from what I've learned
from my parents it was difficult
doctors were like she's got this
condition we can't say what she she will
and won't be able to do
um and yeah it's been a lot of my
childhood in hospital and
transition transitioning into adult care
was a real culture shock you have to
fight for everything
um I feel like when I was a child the
NHS was in a great place like I remember
nurses having time to play games with me
at my you know because I was in hospital
for months on end
um
and I think one of the biggest barriers
now is obviously the The Chronic
underfunding that the NHS has had
um another thing I've experienced is
because a lot a lot of medical
professionals or Consultants I meet they
will only ever read about my condition
when they meet me they treat me like
some sort of phenomena which is
I understand it but it's also annoying
because I'm going to them
for their advice
when you go and see a medical
professional you're going for a hug
essentially because you're the expert
you know in this and you want them to
help you manage your condition but I
don't feel like I always get that I feel
like I have to educate them
um
in addition to that if we talk about
private healthcare
it doesn't cover my condition so as
someone who really relies on the NHS and
the service of the NHS
disproportionately and now there's a lot
of barriers to that because of long
waiting lists and you know etc etc
um it's it's really worrying and then
finally just to add
um we know that there's so much bias
when it comes to Healthcare in lots of
different ways that can be you know your
race your ethnicity but I've had
um consultations with gynecologists who
said yeah you need this operation but
we've never operated on anyone like you
so I'm not gonna do it and that Gary
um so even though you might get in front
of medical professionals they're telling
you that they're not confident to do
their job
yeah with you thank you Shani for saying
all that and let me just say as a
pediatrician if I'd ever seen you in
Awards we would definitely be playing
and you'd definitely get a hug from me
but
um I'm sorry to hear that the medical
profession hasn't always been able to
make you feel cared for in the way that
you deserve as anyone else should
um you're right that to think about some
of the systemic issues that are a play
there it's not about individual
professionals
um always although there is a culture
here that we need to talk about and this
is really where your experience is
really important what we're talking
about here is a kind of discrimination
that's happening
by the very people who you're asking for
help from and you know as you said the
doctors should have the expertise to
deal with this but you're right of
course it's a rare condition how many of
us would have seen seen this
and yet there should be something that's
happening here in terms of how you are
received into the Health Service now I
wonder when you're you know we're
talking about questions of cost and
access
and there are lots of reasons for people
to be quite rightly perhaps hesitant
when it comes to things like Gene
editing therapy
you know at the exhibition
um who if any of you have been looking
at it it points out this line between
editing and enhancing
and I don't think that that line is
always very clear and I'd love to hear
what you've got to say Shawnee about to
you what this means like what does Gene
editing really mean to you and what is
it actually saying about disability
you're absolutely right and it's a
really fine line and we need to talk
about Eugenics as well when we talk
about doing editing so
um
Gene editing wouldn't help me in with my
condition but when I've had genetic
counseling you know I was told if I was
to have a child then there's a 50 chance
that that child would
um be born with the same condition as me
and that affected my decision on whether
I wanted to have kids or not
um I couldn't just barely keep my plants
alive and I didn't want to be
responsible for looking after anybody
else because I genuinely feel like I can
just about look after myself
um I just didn't think it would be fair
to
um you know then potentially raise a
child that would have additional needs
um not you know not bashing anybody who
has you know we all have that option in
our own lives to do what we want to do
right
um and I also have an ethical
voice in my head that thinks well
whilst this is great and this exists and
I believe everybody should have choice
for me personally I think that if I was
really meant to have kids then I think
my body would just be able to do it
personally that's my opinion I feel like
it's a bit too much interfering because
you know I've been told that they can
strip the defective Gene and then
fertilizer I was just like nah it's a
bit too
invasive for me and I just you know but
also I know that I don't have to give
birth to being mother if that's what I
want to do as well
um but I think that some people think
Gene editing is good because then there
will be no disabled people born but
that's not the case because there are
nearly 15 million disabled people in
this country and 83 were born as
non-disabled people
staggering statistic isn't it the
majority of disabled people acquire
their condition and impairment
throughout their working life
and I know that there are countries like
Iceland I believe that
um
it's part of their sort of Pregnancy
Care Gene editing is quite routine and
um
I think in one year like three children
were born with Down Syndrome like
obviously the population of Iceland is
very small but don't you think it would
be really boring if we were all the same
I I think so and I'm gonna come on to
this a bit further like it's not my
condition that disables me
disability is a social construct so we
have to also understand that living with
a condition and an impairment is just an
average part of Being Human but we just
have never been told that no we don't
have that representation
yeah some really profound things yes
[Applause]
yes thank you Shani that is like very
profound what you're saying there and
and this is what this is what I meant
you know like when you're hearing about
this
um and you know I think Jimmy's
experience is a very different one isn't
it in a way and I think that's great and
you know I've had different Medical
Treatments and interventions and by the
way I'm not knocking Healthcare like I
wouldn't have the quality of that of
life that I have without it and maybe I
would feel differently if Gene editing
would be able to help me with my
condition
um but hearing Jimmy's experiences use
life-changing you know why wouldn't you
but I think what you also brought up was
that kind of ickiness that we feel when
it when it comes to things like Gene
editing and gene therapy because it it's
almost like a hits at something so core
to us as human beings like what's inside
ourselves and what actually helps us to
become who we are literally are genetic
alphabets messing around with that
somehow
doesn't feel entirely normal somehow I
want to take a step back here and ask
you Tom
um who you know you've done a lot of
work on this uh um subject you've spoken
to some of the world leading experts on
this
and
having covered all of this stuff for the
last many years you know all of the
advances in gene editing
how familiar do you think the general
public are with the ethical questions
that are concerned here surrounding Gene
editing so not not the technology and
obviously the Fanfare that comes with
any new advance but the ethical
questions and
do you think that public opinion has
shifted in the last few years
um yeah I mean the weird thing is the
speed of this so I've been covering
science for the times since 2011
um which doesn't feel that long for me
um the technology we're talking about
crispr was uh I can I can get into the
timeline of it but but formally
discovered in the form it's in now in
2012 and since then it is I mean I think
it's fair to say that it spread faster
than almost any other laboratory tool in
history
um and definitely it has spread ahead of
the ethical debate um
the the interesting thing is um the
co-discover of it and we can get into
the extent that's true as well because
it's a loads of people involved but the
Jennifer Dowden who's really the face of
crispr
um was well aware of this
um I so I went to see her in 2018
[Music]
um in in UC Berkeley
um and brilliantly she so she she her
lab is on Oppenheimer way
um it's named after Oppenheimer the
creator of the atomic bomb who saw it
explode and said I have become death
destroyer of world I mean actually I
think someone stood next to him said no
you said me it works but but in his
own memory afterwards said I've become
death the story of Worlds and then spent
much of the rest of his career dealing
with the ethical implications and I
think she's very much been the same
um and realized and I I don't think
there's any ethical implications to
sickle cell anemia I I you know other
than the Global Equity things but uh in
the fundaments of the technology I don't
see that's any different from any other
technology but when you get into other
things it does become interesting
um and she convened a conference in 2015
to discuss human germline editing the
idea that you can basically edit human
in evolution and what we do with this
and you know
do we have a total ban for now do we
have a total ban forever and why else
she I remember she talked to him about
this and she convened this whilst it
happened news came out that uh there had
been some Chinese scientists who had
edited human embryos and then destroyed
the embryos but they'd already crossed
that line and what I didn't know and
what she didn't know is whilst we were
talking there was a woman pregnant in
China with a two babies the twin girls
that were going to be born that are the
first crispr babies so we have already
done this
um and uh well just so but very briefly
the the ethics are not easy
um
you will have there were a few diseases
and conditions where you have a single
Gene that you could switch
um so a simple simple example the bracca
one gene uh which uh greatly increased
your chance of breast cancer
um
I don't think many people would have
ethical objections to switching that
maybe
um now you could actually do that in
something called pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis where you select the
embryo that doesn't have it I mean to
call that a more ethical way of going
about things is itself I think far from
Clear
um but I'll give before I so I'll give
one more example that shows to me just I
think how
difficult the ethics are a lot of people
will say in surveys I am for correcting
disease uh in the human genome I'm not
for enhancing I'm not for making your
super baby who's super clever super
these things imagine a putative Gene
which doesn't exist but imagine this
Gene which gives you severe heart
problems and imagine there are three
other forms you can have
one that just gives you a pretty crappy
heart that's fine one that gives you an
average heart and one that gives you the
heart of an athlete now when you change
that Gene which I think most people
would say you should change yeah don't
don't give the gene that's going to kill
you which of those three Alternatives do
you choose and if you choose The
Athlete's heart is that fixing or is it
enhancement
yeah so total Pandora's Box has been
opened hasn't it and I think what's
interesting about the interviews that
you've done with so it's Emmanuel
charpentier and Jennifer doudner who
have been awarded the Nobel Prize for
crispr technology although as you
mentioned and we should mention that
there are lots of scientists who have
been involved in this science Is Never
Done by one person Alone
um you would think that there'd be these
wholehearted proponents for this
technology having come up with it and
it's so interesting to hear that even
they have reservations and that they
have seen that the potential for it is
just so wide and it is exactly this
where we're not able to draw a line a
very in medicine they're really is ever
a clear Line in the Sand of what counts
as wholeheartedly good and what counts
as a wholeheartedly bad
and clearly this is not going to be one
of those easy topics either but I think
it comes back to what you said Shani
about
um
the perception of what disability
actually is because if we accept that we
are all born and we should celebrate our
differences that we are all different
and that we should glory in those
differences
then at which point do some of these
differences become what we call a
disability
and what does that actually saying about
the world that we live in and I want you
to just Riff on that for me Shani what
how does this make you feel when you
think about this so there were two main
modules when it comes to disability
one's called the medical model which we
will all know of even if you don't know
it's called the medical model and one is
called the social model which I alluded
to a little bit earlier
um so as as people that live with
conditions and impairments we we learn
about those conditions and impairments
from non-disabled doctors
um who's who will tell us about our
condition
but what they want the one sentence that
I needed to hear throughout my entire
life remember Medical Professional is
it's society that disables you it's not
this condition not one sentence but I
came across the social model by accident
when I was at University and it changed
my life and it it simply talks about the
fact that
you know it's barriers and bias that
other disabling factors so
you know I'm three foot ten and the
height of a four-year-old there are more
clothes designed for dogs than disabled
people
that's not because of me or my health
condition that's because whoever's in
charge of making and designing and
selling clothes only make them feel
certain types of bodies
the fact that I live in London but only
33 of the tube network is accessible
yeah and when I went on the Elizabeth
line for the first time the other week I
was nearly in tears it's accessible and
beautiful and it can be done
um
sorry so coming back to this it you know
it's not our conditions
um an impairment that disables us
however we do need to be able to manage
them we do need to be able to manage
them in order to live in society but
so ableism is is um the social prejudice
and discrimination of disabled people
it's a lesser known ISM like you have
racism sexism and at its heart ableism
is rooted in the assumption that typical
abilities or non-disabled bodies are
superior but then when we look into that
more that Roots back to productivity and
capitalism because as people we're all
expected to contribute to society and
work and you know put money in and when
you a pension need to take it out but
that's not always going to be the case
and you know I'm sitting here with a lot
of privilege today and something that
um I can't quite get my head around is I
have this privilege because of
colonialism so my grandparents came to
this country as economic migrants and
that's the reason that I was born in
this country like my dad was born in
India oh my God if I had been born in
India
on a farm where my family are in North
India in Punjab I dread to think what my
life would have been like and 80 of
disabled people live in rural rural
areas because of the lack of healthcare
the lack of infrastructure hmm
yeah well again everything that you said
is completely on point and I just want
to just clarify and just underline what
you said there about the distinction
between the medical model of disability
which is basically where it kind of
tries to define a condition or
impairment as one that needs to be cured
in in opposition to what you're saying
which is the social model which is it
argues that actually it's societal
barriers that disable people
um and it's not necessarily the the
condition that needs to to be cured
although of course what we're talking
about is that there are conditions just
like Jimmy's that can be cured with this
therapy and you know as a clinician I'm
looking at the potential of what crispr
can do and there's clear applications
here which are really hopeful I think
um but but just as you said Tom like how
generalizable is that
like what are we willing to actually
apply this to and how will we have those
discussions and I think that's a really
important thing to think about is how do
we have those discussions about what
matters here
yeah I think you're right I think I I
think also weird having said the ethics
has got ahead of the science has got to
have the ethics
the as soon as you start having the
ethics discussion you get so far ahead
of the science
um like essentially we don't know what
most of the genome does
um and uh you can talk about designer
babies but you'd have a real problem
designing them Beyond these few quite
specific conditions um the the other the
other sort of you know you couldn't
we've we've got sort of you know
thousands of genes that are very very
slightly associated with intelligence
um and if you went in and hit them all
you probably end up with all sorts of
other things going on as well and the
the technology is not good enough for
that anyway
um one last week I covered a study as
well that shows one one of the slight
thing I slightly worry about is losing
diversity in a very specific genetic
sense in that we've got all of these
genes that are a product of a long
period of evolution I mean actually you
know as Jimmy will know sickle cell is a
great example of this it's the reason it
persists is because it has historically
given protection against malaria
um and last week I covered a study about
a gene or a genotype a variant which is
um offers offered amazing protection
against the black death
um there's this lovely study where they
study graveyards before during and after
black death and have you had this
variant uh then you were 40 protected
Black Death you were currently protected
to against covid against pneumonia
against all sorts of things and you
could well imagine seeing that data set
and saying
let's give everyone this but the reason
why everyone doesn't of this is outside
of pandemics you are far more likely to
suffer from autoimmune diseases such as
Crohn's and so the the idea that you can
just simp simply go in with these
beautiful scissors go chop chop and Away
you go actually lies the the severe lack
of understanding we still have that you
know so yeah essentially it's way more
complicated than we would like to think
and even with crispr technology which is
precise and which does give us more
control than we've ever heard of our
genetic code
we're basically still are playing with
fire here we don't really know what
we're doing I can actually you seem like
you want to come in here with something
um what what is this all like bringing
up for you in terms of the science
because you're here at the creek you
know this is one of the places that's
leading in terms of the advances in in
genetic editing
uh yeah what are you thinking and what
is the Crick actually doing to take some
of these ethical considerations into
accounts so
um yes Tom raised the point nicely so I
think what's really important in this
conversation is to be really clear about
actually the the central everything that
we're talking about comes down to is it
in our DNA right I said to you Chris
because9 is it crispr is a tool for
editing DNA anything that's in your DNA
can therefore potentially be edited
but what something that is in your DNA
does and the effect that it has is not
necessarily within our control right so
as Tom said certain certain traits
certain things that we're interested in
are sort of diffuse through the through
the genome there's not one place for it
on top of that there's loads of traits
that we seem to care about that aren't
necessarily
um it's not a one-to-one thing it's not
like oh here's a token now you have it
some genes are like that some some bits
of DNA are like that but some of them
are just here's like Tom said a variant
what's a variant it it means something
that makes you slightly more likely to
in the scale of an entire population
right it doesn't necessarily mean
anything about your life as an
individual it means something about your
potential odds in a life in a context of
many other variants doing many other
things right I always give the same
slightly facetious example which is say
I decided to have children and let's say
I went through the IVF route so that I
could try and edit them and help them I
could tweak every Gene I wanted let's
just say it and that happens I tweak
every Gene I want it to every possible
variant that could be possibly useful
for any possible thing let's give them
the best possible chance they have
if that baby is born and I don't feed it
and I don't take it to school and I
don't socialize it and I don't do any of
those things to it all those variants
come to nothing right that's really
important to keep in mind something else
that came up that I think is really
really important to address in this
context exactly as you said is we're in
the Francis Crick Institute right so
we are having an ethical debate about
this this technology in a context where
um if Robin was here he'd be being very
clear about this
it is not allowed to edit human embryos
and implant them in a substantial number
of countries across earth
some countries don't have ethical
guidelines yet and this is something
that people have been discussing since
the day the paper came out Tom also
already alluded to this what's been
incredible about this technology is the
fact that from the day the paper came
out I remember reading it in in 2012 and
we all sat down in a lab meeting I was
at Oxford at the time doing my PhD two
three Labs of like groups of labs sat
together we read this paper and in that
moment we were all discussing
this means that we can change human
beings what does that mean we were
having those conversations in parallel
and that's unprecedented but the Salient
Point here is
places like the Crick host things like
the human genome editing Summit that
happened last week right people are
discussing this across earth what do we
do how do we regulate this what do we
think and you can tell immediately from
attending or listening to any of these
things first of all that there's a huge
diversity of opinion there's diversity
across earth that's already been alluded
to it's very important people regulate
this thing differently and people value
different traits and diseases very very
differently but also people feel very
differently about it depending on
whether or not you're dealing with a
human body a somatic case like Jimmy's
right versus a situation where it's
potentially inheritable so I really
think that that's really that's
important for you to to be aware of
right I think there are a lot of
conversations happening about it a lot
of Institutions are doing a lot of work
around this
but you know it's a tool right this is
the last thing I'll say about this
science tells us how things work right
it's a methodology for figuring out how
things work helps us understand stuff
and crispr is revolutionized the way we
do science how we do experiments it
helps us understand the world better
that Precision is being used to unders
sharpen our knowledge right
but knowledge is not the same thing as
value
human beings decide what is or isn't
valuable right discovering why something
happens or doesn't happen or discovering
that it impacts the organism that
carries this Gene in an apparently
negative way right that is just about
the biological level of life and that
can be true but we can choose to Value
those things extremely differently and
that's where these kinds of
conversations come in right because we
can all decide to Value things very
differently should we wish to
which brings me excellently onto my next
question which is about that how do we
as a society collectively start making
those value judgments about how things
like Gene editing and gene therapy
should be regulated and maybe between
Tom and Ganesh we could have a sense of
what are the current regulations on this
what is the regulatory framework like
for it and are we are things changing
are is there now an opening for things
to be loosened up so to speak
I mean I I think the the the
concern is is that we don't have a world
government and so it's it's not so much
what what the regulations are which as
you've described in the UK you know you
you can't just go ahead and do these
things it's that uh you know scientists
will some scientists might go to the
weakest link in the chain and what I'd
be more interested about is how in
places like the UK we could find a way
to move forward responsibly in the way
that we have done with so-called white
journalists three parent babies but
various other technologies that are
ethically fraught but you have this
mature discussion and then you find a
way to license things and work with
things such that the the power of the
weakest country in the chain is
diminished and scientists think well
I'll go and work in this country which
has the tools and has a framework for
doing it if it's right and if we've had
these conversations yeah
yeah I mean so I should say again this
is where Robin would have been excellent
for you guys uh Robin Robin is involved
in all of these various organizations
the the UN who things like that so there
is a lot of attempts to to have these
sort of regulatory conversations the
important point is
um every country every jurisdiction
effectively has has its own set of
values right and in certain places we
were hearing about this at the human
genome editing Summit in fact last week
some countries have said just no never
never on our watch will this happen
other countries we heard about um Israel
for example has um a piece of
legislation that has an automatic
default every five years where it ceases
to be relevant anymore and that's built
in deliberately to accommodate for the
fact that the technology and the
potential applications of this thing is
going to is changes basically and yeah
that that's what there is to say there
the the UK has always been a for you
know a forerunner for these kinds of
regulatory mechanisms things like the
hfea are used as gold standards across
earth but you know it's up to anybody in
their respective country to decide
whether or not they want to use those
Frameworks right yeah and this interplay
between the national and international
levels in terms of Regulation I think is
very important and very interesting
especially if we come back to that issue
that I mentioned about global inequality
and Jimmy um you know having heard all
of this
where we're at in terms of Regulation
where we're at in terms of disability
rights
um and I just want to come back to that
question of you know how you feel when
you think about
people in different parts of the world
who are not able to access this
technology and who may well even if the
technology was available they might be
different regulations around it which
might make it more unsafe or more
unethical I mean what do you think and I
don't expect you to have the answer to
this but what what do you feel maybe
should be done to make sure that
actually something like Global equality
could be a reality for something like
this
but you know I think that definitely
needs to be a global initiative
particularly for the Sickle Cell because
more than half of the patient population
is outside of the West you know I think
Nigeria has about 4 million patients
that suffer from the disease
so you know God willing if we figure out
a way to cure everyone on the west with
the disease you know we still haven't
touched a fraction of people who are
desperately you know in need of a
solution like this
um I wanted to quickly go back to what
Shawnee spoke about in regards to the um
ethics of it because even myself going
seen firsthand what how the disease has
changed my life you know their days I
wake up and and wonder because I'm a
very spiritual person and and wonder
what have I done you know because this
is such a new technology that is my
research team is still gonna have to
watch me for 15 years to make sure that
I haven't altered or they haven't
altered anything that we don't know
about because crispr hasn't really been
tested in humans the way it has you know
for this specific Sickle Cell trial so I
I completely get those ethical questions
and I think they they need to be Assad
myself every day you know I think and I
I wake up sometimes I feel like I'm an
X-Man and because of how much better I'm
feeling but those days I wonder that you
know what if I was just supposed to die
in my 20s you know maybe that is my part
maybe I wasn't supposed to be cured and
to get to your point doctor in in with
IVF as well with sickle cell I faced a
lot of infertility which led me and my
wife to using IVF to have children so I
have these questions I I often find
myself like maybe this is you know and
it really ties back to that you know
what your destiny is because I'm such a
spiritual person I you know I'm
definitely loving living life you know
not feeling Sickle Cell the way I used
to but there I would be alive if I tell
you that you know they're not days I
think about man what have I done you
know
on the other side of it you know I I
feel a lot better and I am always
thinking back about a lot of and this is
a lot easier to say now that I'm feeling
good but I always find that there's a
beauty in the struggle and obviously for
me the struggle has been sickle cell
and I wonder what if that struggle was
meant to be my destiny and you know now
I feel like only time will tell
yeah it's really beautiful
um this makes me come back to you
Shawnee because
we just had Jimmy beautifully explain
that kind of tension between feeling
like he's playing God on one hand and
actually being a very ordinary humble
human being who has been gifted an
opportunity to live life to the full
when we've been talking about regulatory
Frameworks we've been talking about
National International regulations
to what extent do you feel that the
disability voice and those are the lived
experience you know people like Jimmy
how
how can we incorporate those voices into
those discussions at the time of
developing these Technologies as opposed
to afterwards in a way that means that
the things can be fair and they do
reflect the lived experience more
accurately
um well this is the first time I've been
involved in a conversation like this
um and I think we as a community want to
feel that
included we want to be included we don't
want to feel like it's being done to us
we want to be part of it as well because
you know where the people that live with
this where we're the people that live in
this inaccessible Society
um and I think just coming back to what
Jimmy beautifully shared there
whatever whatever you
sit on this line of yes it's great or no
it's not quite for me it's a very
personal choice and and I'm glad that
choice exists I'm glad it it does exist
and it can help people like Jimmy rather
than if it didn't exist
um I just want to
share something I learned in the last
couple of days
the charity pregnant then screwed who
activated who
um do a lot of activism around child
care costs they shared a step that six
in ten
people terminated their pregnancy due to
the high child care costs wow and it
costs three times more to raise a
disabled child yes so again to me it
comes back to this
point that
if Society was more accessible better
organized if people that design products
for disabled people marketed and price
them fairly
um then it would completely change the
perception of disability and you know
I've met parents of disabled children
who have been given this diagnosis and
they've said to me
it's the diagnosis that was actually the
most scariest thing not not not raising
a disabled child
so we have to get away from this
perception that disability is either
that you're a benefit scrounger or
everyone thinks you want to be a
paralympian it's not it's not that at
all but again what does it come back to
capitalism and very poor representation
of a big part of society wow well said
um we're coming to the close of our main
part of tonight's uh questioning
although I'm now going to throw it to
the audience because this is your
opportunity to ask our amazing panel
questions for yourself
the ethics it's it's clearly crucial and
in a country like the UK we can have
this conversation back and forth but
there are also Rogue countries there
could be Rogue Labs which no matter what
we decide as a society they might just
go and it could be a big country and so
the consequences of them doing say
Eugenics has a consequence for everybody
else in the world as well if they grow
you know the Superman or Superwoman
whatever that is right how do we deal
with that how do we think about so the
ethic problems outside our society
that's a fantastic question and it
doesn't just limit itself to gene
therapy I often think about what's
happening in other countries so
um who wants to take this this question
yeah I feel like
um especially after the human genome
editing Summit that happened literally
last week in this building I feel like
um lots of people talked about that
basically so
um well and also importantly as Tom said
we already live in a post-human genome
edited world right there are three girls
that live
um with uh edited genes on Earth already
um but the the reception was
um extremely
um
present
um and the Chinese government the these
experiments were conducted in China have
subsequently changed their legislation
and rules about these things and their
regulations substantially
um but ultimately we can't
that's the uncomfortable thing about a
society
right all of us we can't control it what
we can do is we can have conversations
invite people to be part of the
conversation and sit around the same
table and things like the the human
genome editing Summit were such a great
example of that because there were
people from all over Earth
coming to talk about how should we do
this what should we do these are our
concerns
um but that's about it because
ultimately we don't have any control
we can influence we can have those
conversations but we don't have a world
government that's that's the reality
brilliant did anyone else want to come
in um actually I want to ask a question
of Julie because I'm going to pop in
because I think this this may get to
something interesting one thing that I'm
thinking listening to you is if we could
move on to uh Human Genome of germline
editing into designer babies in some
sense if you could imagine a situation
in which it was possible to entirely
eradicate Sickle Cell not not to cure it
but given it is such a simple genetic
condition to eradicate it from the Earth
forever to have permanently evolved
Humanity out of it would you do it
no pressure
I do it every day and twice on Sundays
[Laughter]
yeah I'm living with sickle cell you
know even I just mentioned you know I
have this debate in my head as to what
lies I had in the future with what I've
done but every day if that decision was
placed in front of me to completely
eradicate Sickle Cell for me personally
and for everyone else I would give them
that decision but there's I got to be
honest and say this is more of my
opinion I know a lot of people that live
with the disease that I've become so
enmeshed with the disease and it's
become a part of who they are and that
was actually one of the difficulties I
faced after the transplant is this
identity of who Jimmy is without Sickle
Cell so there's going to be that issue
at play with patients that have genetic
diseases that they incur at Birth you
know it becomes literally their identity
and I've spoken to patients who are
going through
hell with sickle cell but are not
interested in having you know Gene
editing because they they don't know
life without sickle cell
Johnny you wanted to come in yeah um
Sophie had asked me that question and
I'm someone where there isn't a cure you
know there's nothing that can really
take away the condition that I have I
now would answer no no I wouldn't
because I feel like when we ask people
that question especially
to people that whether it isn't a cure I
feel like what we're asking them is is
your life valuable yes do you want to
live and I know you probably didn't mean
that
um well I hope you didn't mean that
um but even though when people then you
know ask me well you know well you're
saying you wouldn't have a child with
the same condition as you and the
difference is is that I have a lot of
privilege living in this country I'm a
palatable disabled person let's be
honest that comes with privilege but
I've done the work like I've done the
work to be happy with who I am and I
wouldn't be who I am without my
condition
yeah I mean look I think it's
complicated isn't it it's it's not
straightforward and there's so many
things that we are born with in terms of
traits that we could select for and you
know one of the questions actually from
somebody who's watching online is how do
we make sure that we don't perpetuate
these harmful discriminatory social
norms over other things like race gender
height I mean you know these are all
things that maybe I would like to select
for but you know this this is where
we're talking about the line where do we
draw the line how do we make sure that
this this doesn't happen
Ganesh do you have any thoughts how do
we make sure that we don't start
selecting for things like this well I
mean first of all there's a question
about how can you even select for those
things for some things sure but for some
things no right now that's the point not
everything is not every I I could have
again we're back to the analogy right I
have an embryo I give it all the best
possible genes if I don't feed it it's
not going to be even if I'd given it
every gene on Earth let's say or variant
on earth that could make it 6 seven
let's say I wanted that
um but you know it's not going to change
that right so there are some things that
are within our power and some things
that aren't and there are also moments
where there are appropriate Technologies
and and this is a really great
technology to have available as an
option as a tool that is on the table
right but again
the existence of a tool does not tell us
when we want to use it right
100 again so it comes back to this idea
of science being a tool for us as a
society to use in ways that we
collectively decide are wise so one of
the things I find interesting about this
though is let's say that a proportion of
the world do want to do this they do
want to select the children and we have
the ability to do it let's say you know
we are able to select children who are
consistently 15 IQ points higher than
the the Baseline which would be
absolutely massive well that group of
the population which will be in the west
because they'll be the ones who can
afford it and we'll also be the ones
who've decided I don't have a problems
with this well you've potentially
created the ruling class
um and everyone else can opt out of it
but then they suddenly find that they're
they're not the ones with the children
who are 15 IQ plus and I used to think
that's more of a problem but now again I
think we're going to be completely
destroyed by the robots anyway so it's
it's utterly moot now join in for next
week on artificial intelligence
um there are more questions within the
the rooms I'd like to yes yeah just
building on the point of other
revolutions going on we've heard that
there's great excitement in the lab and
there's quite ethical challenge I I'm
not quite clear I'd like your feedback
on
to what extent it would be a great
health Revolution
in the sense that if we can use crispr
we can maybe change the microbiome in
our gout and feel healthier we can help
animals be healthier but I'm not quite
clear beyond the five million that I
think Tommy's saying it yet absolutely
we should have a Jimmy sorry a cure for
how many people if the growth in crispr
that's gone on over the last decade in
the lab continues for another decade
beyond that five million how many people
potentially do have conditions that that
are addressable great question well
have you counted them uh
this is going to sound like a facetious
answer but it's not everybody
is the point right effectively
everybody who has DNA and has any kind
of Health anything situation
existing pre-existing or simply aging
related right all of us are susceptible
to the whims and mercies of our bodies
whether we like it or not and so this
tool allows us to invent new
technologies understand those mechanisms
better find new Solutions and cures and
address every single one of those things
that has a foot in DNA
theoretically
so that's why this is a health
Revolution it's so not sexy to be like
yeah because DNA editing is like amazing
and it's not it's not immediately
apparent but just honestly take a moment
to appreciate this anything on Earth
that has DNA can be edited right whether
that's the bacteria in our guts whether
it's the animals whether it's the
parasites the plants our entire
ecosystem every fish in the ocean every
human on earth
theoretically
should we wish to
why not we're already listen there's
already been people who've had their
sickle cell disease cured right the
important point is
we start with situations where it's
deemed ethical because these are just
individual bodies we're not affecting
theoretically The Inheritance so you
start there and you start with a single
Gene situation like Sickle Cell
something that is very very obvious one
gene has one error in it it leads to a
debilitating disease
who wouldn't do something with that the
real heart of this question the quandary
that is crispr is you have a tool on the
table to cure everything that is
possibly encoded in DNA right
importantly it was also raised that
these things kind of occur spontaneously
and whatnot so it will never cure all
disability or all health conditions
that's not the point
but it can definitely provide
alternative Solutions and whatnot the
point is the tools on the table once
it's out once it exists what is more
ethical to use it wisely or to not use
it at all
[Applause]
so look we've got lots more questions
please do come and ask ask the questions
um it's just one quick one in terms of
uh can you just come a bit close to the
mic that's right so it's not made for
you yeah
long jeans uh so in terms of um if
you're to edit say a single sales we're
talking about earlier that's the big
discussion at single cell level
do you then find out
um
when that's turned into a human body is
Australian cells enough to find out okay
have we had an unintended consequence
here or we would need to wait several
human generation journal and cell
generation several human lifetimes to
find out oh actually you know grandkids
from that editing that's gone a bit
wrong
great question how long do we have to
wait to know that we've messed up
it depends biology has a biology has a
way of of showing its hand with time so
effectively if it's really important
you'll find out pretty quickly if it's
relevant it might take a bit longer
um and it depends it depends entirely
you know and transgenerational effects
do happen I think something that is very
important to keep in mind though is
bizarrely I think whenever we talk about
these um sort of hypotheticals where we
use this technology and things happen I
think people sort of forget that the
tool continues to exist so it's not that
you use it one time and then it's like
oh no like we've completely messed it
all up and there's nothing we can do
that's not how it works the tool remains
there once you start tinkering the
tinkering I mean once you start
tinkering the tinkering commences and
the important Point here is we're
already tinkering with everything that
we're doing
like us sitting here in this room right
now with the lives that we have led is
already a far cry from what nature was
intending for us so just keep that in
mind as well brilliant next question I
was just wondering if you could give a
little detail on how this actually
happens so Jimmy how big a medical
procedure was it how long did it take
um you know you talked about the number
of cells we're talking about that seems
inconceivable that you can do it I
understand it in the lab but I was just
wondering how does that actually work in
a person thank you that is a brilliant
question Jimmy can we just have your
lived experience of what is it like to
have gene therapy in a nutshell for
everybody and then we'll talk about it
was a pretty cumbersome medical
experience I think it took about a year
um they had to go through I had to go
through three main parts the first part
was the collection where they collected
the stem cells and that took about four
months and then you go through the
conditioning basically wiping out your
system preparing it for your new edited
brand new DNA or stem cells and then the
final part will be the infusion where
they Infuse your new cells and then your
you know your white cells are knocked
out so you need to be in the hospital
for a long period of time so it was
quite a long period I think all together
it took just about a year
um so so one thing I think is worth
saying is with these cures you're not
that is not every cell in Jimmy's body
and and some of the things that you look
at so another really promising area is
uh macular degeneration and you look at
that because the eye first of all is a
contained vessel so you're just doing it
in that it's safer for various reasons
and you're looking at just changing the
cells in the eye so the rest of you
would contain all the whatever mutation
it is that gives you this degenerative
blindness but the bit of ute which is
actually pertinent where that Gene's
expressed is the one that you're making
the changes
um so that so you wouldn't be looking to
do every every trillion cells so only a
bit of Jimmy is X-Men
even though he feels like an accent
clarification
who want to ask questions which is
fantastic thank you so much for coming
forward
thanks so much
um one of the things that I was thinking
of when listening to this conversation
was that it actually you know a lot of
other Technologies are like this in the
sense that the science runs far ahead of
the regulations right crispr was
compared to Smartphones at the start and
those are also revolutionary in the
sense that they you know give you the
full repository of human writing as well
as let you communicate instantaneously
with everyone in the world and now the
UK and the US governments are thinking
about maybe say uh putting restrictions
on tick tock so even about sort of
designer babies we might not have that
right now but of course you know sex
selective abortions have been in
practice for a very long time and are
actually currently probably more
practice outside of the West than within
it so to what extent you know we talk
about trying to impose order and rules
but is it in some sense the whole world
like a petri dish right here is where
the Industrial Revolution started we've
been dumping greenhouse gases into the
the atmosphere for hundreds of years and
we still don't know the consequences so
aren't we being a bit naive when we
consider that we might even be able to
like how optimistic is it to say we will
have a rule-based order for this
so one of the things I find fascinating
you can do this yourself
um I've you know you there are people
who have crispered themselves for
various things
um because it's tried to yes we don't
know how successful they are
um but you know can you just for the
audience's sake tell them what you mean
when you say crispy yourself will they
if they've bought the because these
aren't I mean it's hard but it's not you
know at most decent labs in the country
can do this in the world and you can you
can send off for the DNA Target you want
you can send off for the crispr cast 9
system and I don't know how to do it but
you know how to do it yeah so I mean
okay I can't believe I'm about to talk
about this in public so
well as I said when this when the first
when the technology was first published
and people were talking immediately
about how important this thing is and
alongside that came a movement of people
who call themselves sort of biohackers
or independent researchers and things
like that
they are basically people who are
interested in the democratization of
this technology right which is a good
idea effectively right we're all that's
effectively what we're all talking about
there's this this concern that we have
who has access to these things to what
end
I said at the beginning the thing that
makes Christmas so special is that it's
precise and then I sort of tacked on oh
well it's also quite quick and cheap as
well just like as the throwaway because
the heart of the debate is to do with
the Precision but actually you're
completely right on this is really
really cheap
to access you don't need much in the way
of complicated material to be able to
just do it on a small scale
so people in the biohacking community
and independent research Community have
been trying to do this and they have
successfully you know you can you can
genome bacteria or Yeast or plants and
things like that at home and some people
were doing injecting themselves in fact
and there was a lot of conversation
about that at the time because it was
like what are you doing why are you
trying to do this and you know how are
you going to control this how are we
going to control how are we going to
control this that was the big
conversation the question
and the thing about that Community is
and this is effectively the same thing
that we're talking about in terms of
sort of global regulation points is how
do you control someone well we we call
it Society
right that's what we call it we call it
having conversation having a community
whatever you want to call it it's
it's what your friends and peers deem to
be acceptable and we have these bizarre
mechanisms by which we make it clear to
other people that you just don't do that
or if you do it we alienate you because
we don't like that and that sounds
really non-scientific but that's the
reality of how cultures affect human
behavior and that's this is no different
to that basically I would say
yeah um there is a lady in pink who has
a microphone it's um a question for um
Jimmy in the first instance
um first of all I just want to say how
really really happy I am for you that
you're living a pain-free life and able
to enjoy being being a fulfilled
pain-free person so that's that's
fantastic
um I was just wondering you talked about
some of the um ethical issues that you
grappled with post-treatment you know is
this right um what about everyone else
who may need help who doesn't have
access to help either through
um
Side by means that because of where they
are politically or economically Etc or
through geography
um what ethical discussions or debates
did you have with your medical
practitioners prior to your treatment
and were those debates a part of the
treatment package and was your treatment
contingent upon these debates or did you
only really have to think about these
issues post-treatments
yeah really great question is basically
how much did you have to individually
think about the ethical issues like came
to your own treatment yeah Jimmy tell us
um to be completely honest I didn't
think about it a lot at all actually I
was really really desperate uh at the
time pre-transplant um my wife was eight
months pregnant
um Sickle Cell had won every battle with
me in my life and fatherhood was a
battle I wanted to win so I I went in
head burst no questions asked it hasn't
been until I've had the transplant I've
been able to look back and ask myself
these questions like wow
look at what I had just done and you
know all the fair points you brought up
as to you know where I'm from how
they're not going to get access to this
for for God knows how long but no I had
no um ethical debates with myself I
actually my wife actually had to force
me to read the consent form because I
didn't even I just wanted to sign and go
and then she had to force me listen you
could get all of these crazy things that
you know it said 15 years from now you
can get leukemia and all these and I
didn't even care I just wanted to sign
and go
thank God for your wife
um
um I just want to make sure that this
side of the room if you've got questions
you're being seen I just realized I've
got my back to you but is there anyone
on this side who wants to ask a question
I knew it
so I was wondering what are the do you
have any examples of specific
um enhancements say for once the best
road that you could make right now that
would make someone better as you know a
loaded question but
are there any exams you can think of I'm
going to put quotation marks around the
better I was going to say good please
define better in this I mean I don't
know what to say what okay the classic
enhancement narrative it revolves around
putting genes in that shouldn't be there
at all right so for example
um we could oh eyes there's a good one
okay so eyes are easy enough to deliver
it or easy enough relatively easy to
deliver into the easiest system in fact
is of course the blood system which is
why we Sickle Cell but let's save the
eyes we could probably insert genes that
are helpful for making different kinds
of you know that in the back of your
eyes you have rods and cones they're
different receptors for different kinds
of light yeah well different species on
earth have different forms of those that
allow them to see different kinds of
wavelengths and things like that look at
this Tom's on Board sign him up no
consent form required
um but yeah so we could do that there
you go how's that for a theory we could
insert some genes from other species
that are known to have really
interesting effects and see what happens
one that's also being discussed a fair
bit is to do with um like space travel
so human beings sending human beings
into space yeah it's the thing you know
if you want to send a manned mission to
Mars you need to change human bodies
because we're not exactly adapted to
living under intense radiation we we
live on a planet with a nice soft ozone
blanket fair enough it's got a hole in
it but yeah you know you don't have that
out in space so there's already talk
about you know which genes would we need
to alter in human beings to make them
more resilient to to
space travel yeah all right it's
absolutely bizarre isn't it when you
start thinking about what might be
possible right now
um I've got a this really interesting
question
um from someone online a Marissa de
Souza who has asked how should consent
be dealt with especially with germline
editing and should individuals be able
to make decisions about their own
genetic enhancement or should society as
a whole have a bigger say in how far
Gene editing is allowed to go Shani do
you have any thoughts on this
yeah
I think as I said earlier that I'm glad
the option for Gene editing exists just
you know Jim is a brilliant example of
that enhancements is is a different
Arena isn't it
um
I feel like
Society already dictates that some
bodies are more valuable than others so
we kind of already have that so you know
um
if you're not able to work or be
productive in society then you're seen
as less valuable and you know benefit
treat that kind of narrative
um I feel like we're already there but
no I I don't think that Society should I
think it should be an individual
decision but not about enhancements
about editing yeah and what this
question is getting at is this the
germline editing so it's not where it
goes beyond just you you and your body
but if you had kids yeah they would also
potentially take that on I mean this is
we're talking about
editing out literally the evolution of
the human species and I wonder if you
guys have um thoughts on this in terms
of consent around this and who should be
making those decisions
I mean if we decide as a society to do
that then they're literally the only
people who can give the consent to the
parents
um I mean I think the easiest thing in
the world would be to say no we should
never do it but I think you very rapidly
end up with situations where you think
well is it is it wrong not to do it
and I'm going to be really contentious
here and say it's already happening
sorry the lives in the sense of
literally the life you live in the body
that you are in prior to having children
will impact how your children turn out
right no one's asking me oh goodness
should you put the burger down stop
eating fatty things you know don't you
know no but I mean serious like it
sounds like I'm being ridiculous but
it's true sorry the lives we live
already impact the Next Generation
actually I think Shani said something
that was really key to this thing
I think crispr has held up a mirror to
us all and how uncomfortable we feel
actually about the control that we as
human beings have I think that's
actually what's happening right so far
we've done all sorts of things human
beings have changed all sorts of stuff
right as I said before ain't nothing
natural about what's happening right now
but we've never really felt quite so
like hi what would you do
about it right and and and we're we're
having that moment where the microphone
is being shoved into our faces
collectively and I think a lot of us are
feeling that natural instinct to shrink
back and go oh
um also I mean in terms of germline
editing of my children you know the idea
that I'm creating something that goes
down the generation I mean the the power
I have to already do that in simply
choosing who my wife is is considerably
larger than crispr and considerably you
know more control given we do understand
what's going to happen there you know my
wife
I've already
got got a whole Suite of genes which I'm
going to get half of in my children or
my children are getting it half of and I
can see how they've turned out there so
it's almost as if you're inviting us to
think about what we already can do and
we already have control over and to then
re re-evaluate what control in this
context actually means look the
conversation is fascinating we have
literally one minute left
um do we have time for one more question
one more question from the floor and
you've been waiting very patiently so
I'm gonna I'm gonna allow you to come
forward thank you very much
um I think quite often we we see that
um legislation and ethics can kind of
fall behind uh the development and then
you also talked about how ethics can
then run ahead of what's actually
capable
um do you think that that's kind of an
unhelpful sci-fi Vision or maybe it can
actually or even cause fear-mongering or
kind of help predict and anticipate
legislation so that these things can be
read like like regulated better
a really really cool question
I think
um well I think that this is a tool and
that human beings choose how they will
their tools so the fact that this
conversation runs way ahead of what the
science is capable of is a really good
thing because it helps us process as a
collective what we want to do and don't
want to do
um another arena in which we already do
that which is
um far less scary sounding than like
regulation and legislature and all that
sort of stuff is sci-fi actually science
fiction books and like TV shows and
things like that they allow us to run
the thought experiment and imagine these
things and to to sort of engage with
these ethical quandaries in a really
tangible and fun kind of way but also
genuine way and they do shape how we
feel about it and and what I'm
ultimately saying is
the conversations we have will shape how
we feel about using the tool the tool
doesn't change right it will just change
how we feel comfortable or don't feel
comfortable using It ultimately so more
more conversations
and briefly just to add I took part in
the nhs's 100 000 Genome Project and um
so you I went and gave my blood as did
my mom and dad and it was to try and see
if we could find out why I why I was
born with the condition and for years
and years and years we're like yeah we
haven't found anything and then they
wrote to me back I think in 20
I don't know a few years ago and they
said we've got some news for you
and I never did anything about it and I
found that letter the other day and I
just think I forgot about it but like
what's gonna change in my life really
knowing about it like like if I was
really interested then cool but and like
one part of me does want to find out
it's not going to change anything and
actually my mom was like oh why do you
want to blame one of us is in the moment
I was like no I was like but you know
but I did I wanted to be part of that
project to also help you know with
science and future Generations as well
so you're absolutely right these tools
are tools but really
the change we think that they might make
to some people it doesn't matter and we
don't want it
yeah and this is the importance of
having a collective conversation like
we've had tonight and it has been a
scintillating conversation I have
certainly found it thought provoking I'd
like to extend my thanks to Shani danda
Ganesh Taylor Jimmy olajara thank you so
much for joining us and Tom Whipple and
I'd also like to thank Intelligence
Squared for putting on this event for
all of us together of course our hosts
the Crick Institute
um the brilliant cuts and paste
exhibition which is on here at the
Francis Crick Institute in London is
going on until December 2023 but don't
wait until then to go and see it if you
haven't seen it already please go now
and obviously finally a massive thank
you to our amazing audience for all of
your thought-provoking questions thank
you for joining us this evening good
night
[Applause]
thank you